as we look out right now it's gorgeous
out there you see the snow on the spring
mountains and we've got some of that
early light clouds from yesterday have
slipped away they're gone and that means
we've got a good sunny day coming our
way it's 31 up there at kyle canyon but
we've had some breezy winds off and on
overnight 31 at red rocks gonna be a
chilly morning for a bike ride or a hike
so dress warm everybody and nice layers
lots of 30s around the valley just a
couple of spots left in the 40s 20s in
indian springs below freezing in perum
42 in boulder city but 33 in mesquite
with teens caliani and ely this morning
and some north winds down in laughlin
mid 50's and those north winds at times
are back up over 25 miles an hour a
couple of cold fronts the northeast the
northwest right in the middle of the
country a warm front and that has really
produced some warmer temperatures where
places like rapid city and sioux falls
were below zero
just a few days ago they are now up in
the 30s this morning they're like oh
that's so warm but for them that's
pretty mild so remember all those clouds
that we had pushed into our area
yesterday all from a low off the coast
of baja yesterday it was up here near la
now it's been sliding south
further south and it's going to sit
there for a couple of days so we're kind
of in between high clouds we're going to
be fine today even into tomorrow we're
looking for good sunshine yesterday 59
for the high today a little warmer into
the low 60s not much in the way of winds
for the valley tomorrow even mid 60s a
very mild week ahead and then clouds
will be moving in for thursday and no
rain we're just looking for the clouds
from that system down south and also a
system that will slide by from the north
so thursday looks to be a pretty cloudy
day mostly sunny on friday the weekend
looks great it's a three-day holiday
weekend for kiddos mlk monday holiday
and 60s hang on through next week